sending a private jet people who need it
more no water no food no nothing
zero and you are seeing I'm here against
terrorists don't miss this amazing
opportunity from Nature's blends to get
your finest premium black seed oil and
to get that energy levels back up
check them out
now brothers and sisters and dear
friends Floyd Mayweather has not only
put his support for Israel he has also
set a private jet with food Shel water
and ammunition and uh body armor and all
that kind of stuff what makes me sick to
my stomach is not the fact that you know
if there is people in need no problem
standing with them supporting them
helping them food no I have no problem
with that at all if this is the case you
talking about a state who is
wellestablished well established so much
so that they are dropping white
phosphorus bombs on Palestinians they've
killed over 500 kids now I want to
question Mayweather I want to question
him what kind of a vile human being are
you not that sending a Plane full of
these things to Israel the point is they
don't even need that so who you sucking
up to huh who you sucking up to the
Palestinians are being bombed Left Right
Center
500 kids have been killed massacred you
coward you coward and you are sending a
private jet full of these eyes those
things should go to Palestinians not
that it shouldn't go to Israelis
Israel's established state who's been
sto they have stolen these lands they
have running water they have everything
they got America they got United Kings
they've got everyone behind their back
the point I'm trying to say is the
people that genuinely need it you don't
even bat an i where are the support for
the Palestinians you scum you bastard
you are you are a scum where is your
support for the Palestinians huh who are
you trying to prove what to huh sending
a private jet people who need it more no
water no food no sh nothing zero and you
are saying I'm here supporting this you
know against terrorists no problem let's
suppose Hamas is a terrorist terrorist
no problem because of them killing
innocent people what about Israel who
have killed more than Hamas could ever
do why do you condemn both why do you
call both terrorists then if we're going
to be if the sh fits why don't we do
that look at the definition of terrorism
doing acts of violence against innocent
people for political gains why do you
not call Israel that you scum huh and
I'm going to leave it on this brothers
and sisters Allah subhana wa T says in
the Quran forget this Freud Mayweather
yes this little flipping scum yes
that's what he is that's what he is
Allah says in the
Quran
for
and Allah says in the Quran and who
enforced Justice when wronged the reward
of an evil deed it is its equivalent but
whoever Pardons and seeks reconciliation
then the reward is with Allah he
certainly does not like the wrongdoers
there is no blame on those who enforce
Justice after being wronged blame is
only only on those who wrong people and
transgress in the land unjustly it is
they who will suffer a painful
punishment and whoever endur patiently
and forgives surely there is a resolve
to to Aspire to this is from the Quran
this is from the Quran and the matter is
clear shame on Justin bber shame on
Mayweather shame on all of those
individuals who are supporting Israel
Israel Israel Israel but not a single
thing to the innocent Palestinians who
have been bombed by the terrorist State
Israel may Allah deal with them inshah
may Allah subhana wa taala deal with
them and expose them for what they are
that's all I have to say send this to
this coward Mayweather you are a coward
shame on
you